this is a production of Cornell
University
and I want to thank you for the great
welcome and the great turnout it's
really an honor for me to be here Susan
mentioned that I work for a company
called indigo egg which is into the
plant microbiome we develop into fights
for the benefit of crop production we
also do partnerships with growers and
risk mitigation we characterize crops
that are grown and segregate those and
try to market that through identity
preservation I mentioned that because my
job with indigo is I head up university
relationships and partnerships
particularly in my job is to focus on
those those campuses that are of
strategic interest and importance to me
indigo and Cornell is one of those
Cornell I'd say Texas A&M is another
Kate we do a lot with k-state a lot of
our workers is in wheat and so there's
only really a handful of campuses and we
were a delegation from indigo was here
last August and we had one-on-one visits
with folks like dr. McCutchen and others
and we're not just interested in
microbiology or the plant microbiome
because of our interest in segregation
and trying to market and capture greater
value out of crops crop quality
utilization food safety food performance
all of those aspects are important to us
and that's that's why I'm here this is
my third trip to Ithaca since since last
August I've been here many many times
before through the biofuels work but
it's good to be back and it's good to be
back
and so thank you for so it's nice
weather I came here I came here from
Brookings South Dakota I still live in
Brookings and I go to Boston two or
three times a month but my wife's gonna
have 35 below temperatures tonight not
windchill factor that's going to be the
air temperature so we'll have 50 below
zero a wind chill back home and I won't
be there so so so thank you for that
the things that I've done at South
Dakota State there's just like any other
institution I imagine there's some very
interesting historical figures that have
had any impact on agriculture
agricultural science and we have our
share of those at South Dakota State as
well and I'll really do a deep dive on
one of them here today that that's Edgar
McFadden but there's a couple others as
well that I might make mention of and of
course these stories interfere with
other places including New York and
Cornell I do want to point out as I get
going and developing this story that I
become passionate about and actually a
wake up at night with a new idea on
where to search I've been to Rockefeller
Foundation archives the National
Archives very of many university
archives but I've had a partner in that
and she's in the room Cindy Bartel she
didn't know I was going to introduce her
but Cindy's a postdoc here at Cornell in
the Atkinson Center and before she went
to grad school she I was able to wrangle
her into helping me out with some of
these searches and Thank You Cindy
because a big part of this was was
because of you so thank you thank you so
much
she's just been wonderful to work with
so let's get into this story and who was
Edgar McFadden and what what type of
advancement and contributions did he I
had the word contributions what were his
contributions to wheat improvement well
at least where I'm gonna pick up on the
story it written the story begins before
this but I'm gonna pick up on this story
in Lisbon New York it's up in st.
Lawrence County just south of the st.
Lawrence River it was the first
community established in that County in
that part of New York I think it was
1801 or something like that that the
town of Lisbon was created think people
think it was named after Lisbon Portugal
but it's actually Liz born or Lisburn
Ireland that it's named after just right
outside
Northern Ireland so an Irish community
in New York
James McFadden was born in 1856 there
Lisbon is still there it's about a
population of about 4,000 people and he
did his he was a college or graduate of
Portsmouth Teachers College in in or
Potsdam Teachers College in New York so
he got his degree and started a career
in in teaching after he got his degree
he left New York and moved to central
Minnesota to begin his teaching career
and he met a young lady there there was
eight years younger that he was and that
was Beatrice they pronounced that
Beatrice her name was Beatrice talking
and eventually they were married and
they moved in left Minnesota and
homesteaded in Dakota Territory Dakota
South Dakota was not a state yet but in
the mid 1800s they left Minnesota to
homestead in Des County South Dakota and
they had a family they had three
children they had Lily Lily was the
oldest and ger was the middle child
Edgar sharp McFadden he was really the
tail end child because the brother
Clarence died in infancy about eight
which is not an unusual occurrence in
that part of the world this is where
Dade County went they live just right
outside of Webster South Dakota it's
going to get down to about 40 degrees
below zero there tonight that's the
environment that they were living in and
by the way winners were hard a hundred
years ago there as well so the family
underwent just tragic hard times for one
reason or another beginning in 1899
Clarence died infancy I still don't know
what he he died of but it wasn't an
uncommon thing for people to die as
youngsters
at that period of time so that was a
tragedy to the family meanwhile they
were farming they're trying to make a
living off of 160 acres of land and in
that that part of the world they had a
couple milk cows and they had some
chickens and so Edgar and his dad would
sell milk and cream and egg deliveries
into the town of Webster they lived six
miles out of town so he would be
involved in that with those dairy
deliveries and he learned the value of
hard work and man it was hard work but
Edgar was a unique individual and that's
a key thing to remember in this talk he
later wrote that by age 13 he had read
the work of gosh from having one of my
senior moments there right now so so the
Mendelian he wrote Gregor Mendel's
work and that wasn't rediscovered
remember it was rediscovered in Europe
in 1900 so by 1904 Edgar said that he
had reviewed and he was studying
Mendel's work he had already read
Darwin's Origin of Species by that age
as a very young man now the question
I've had that I haven't been able to
find out is someone living in Webster
South Dakota Dade County South Dakota
how do you access that that work how do
you get access to that and that's
something that I have yet to figure out
but nevertheless I believe that he did
it I believe a hundred percent I'm
convinced that he did it because by 1904
from his review and study of Mendel's
work he was already doing some of his
own selection work out in the field on
his own farm in South Dakota he wanted
to develop a beardless line of wheat so
no Hans and he was going on into fields
and trying to put to the test this this
segregate
a week he wasn't doing any crosses or
anything like that or there's always
already making his own population
developing his own populations and
studying segregates so he was doing that
on his own as a young man by the time
1904
so 1904 comes along and early in that
spring his father was gored by the
family bull so that's kind of a
reflection of what it was like to live
there he wasn't killed but he was
severely injured and it impacted him for
the rest of his life so his father was
was was injured in 1904 in 1904 they had
a sudden severe stem stem rust epidemic
that reduced their crop by about fifty
to sixty percent and when you're living
in that type of a situation just think
about the economic impact that has on a
family in a community in the whole
region so a huge impact there
so Edgar dedicated his life as a young
man trying to do what he could to
understand what he eventually became
that came to know it as as a stem rust
the science of stem rust he wanted to
know about wheat and and this whole area
of breeding and genetics and wheat so
that intrigued him for the rest of his
entire life and so uh what followed up
after that as he was getting on his way
in science on his own remember he had
about of eighth grade education at this
period of time 1908 comes around and his
older sister Lily at age 19 and then his
mother was getting sick so one tragedy
after the other so they moved they still
main
ownership of the farm in Dade County
South Dakota they kept that and they
rented it out essentially but the family
picked up and moved all three of them
and actually they went to Orange County
California first to see what they could
see what kind of life they might have
there and spent a few months with some
relatives out there but ultimately they
moved to Ballmer a Texas in this this
part of Texas Pecos County 1908 just
north of the Davis Mountains so you can
kind of see some topography there that's
the Davis Mountains and at that period
of time that was the haunt of Bandidos
out of Mexico folks like Pancho Villa
were actually hiding and living and
operating in that part of Texas crossing
the Rio Grande River and then they would
come in that deeply into Texas into the
Davis Mountains
well what Edgar was doing while they
lived and tried to maintain this the
small cattle ranch down in Texas Edgar
would follow the wheat harvest and bear
in mind that there weren't combines at
that period of time wheat was harvested
manually its size and it up and then it
would be thrashed and so he would follow
that he would become part of these
harvest crews and follow the wheat
harvest all the way up into North Dakota
every year but given his interest he was
paying attention to stem rust spores
stem rust infections out in the field
what was the morphological stage of
maturity of wheat as he was going
through what was the condition of this
week and he was taking notes and
learning all who all along the way so he
was doing that on his own as a young man
going from Texas to up into the northern
Great Plains
photograph of Edgar the family had this
Kodak camera and they took lots of
pictures and some of those still exist
today so this is a photograph of edy
Kerr it's gonna be about 1908 nine
somewhere in that figure down in Texas
and see he's got a double-barreled
shotgun there and he's got a six-shooter
sticking in his belt with a with a belt
full of cartridges that he so this is
that this is he would call himself a
range writer and definitely he was a
genuine cowboy Texas cowboy during this
period of his of his life that's Edgar s
McFadden right there
so what else was going on 100 years ago
during this same period of time we had a
monumental figure in Plant Pathology and
we genetics at the University of
Minnesota Elvin statement and there's
testament to him still on campus I was
just in statement Hall just last week
Elvin Stegman was recognized as the
world's global expert on Puck's Tinian
at that period of time he established a
laboratory for for essentially
epidemiology of these diseases and wheat
and other small grains it was also an
advocate for Barbary eradication Barbary
as an alternate host to to Puck's
Indiana's believe that that Barbary was
a source of infection for wheat wheat
crop up and down the Great Plains so a
important figure here is Elvin statement
and by the way Elvin Stegman was a major
advisor for Norman Borlaug later on in
statements career
a couple other figures one that I've
developed an even longer talk about and
that's Nils Hanson Mills Hanson was a
professor of horticulture at South
Dakota State University
he was the first USDA plant Explorer
hired by Tama James Wilson Secretary of
Ag at the turn of the century and he
made six expeditions into Russia to
bring back germ plasm for USDA's planet
introduction system a lot of it was
alfalfa he's got a big bundle of
Siberian alfalfa there under under his
arm and that's how he looked yet he's
got a little six-shooter there and his
belt as well with a billy club he liked
to pose for pictures but he brought back
a lot of small grains apples still today
a lot of that those introductions and
apples are used today a lot of
horticultural crops cabbages cucurbits
you mentioned it
alfalfa crested wheatgrass a lot of
those things smooth brown grass were
first introduced by unions handsome and
then Mark Carlton mark Carlton was also
a USDA explorer he hailed out of Kansas
and many of our small grains
introductions around the turn century
Durham's bread wheats Emmer's rye oats
barley those types of things they were
introduced by Mark Carlton there was a
lot of development in wheat in the
northern Great Plains and Canada during
this period of time and we can't get
into all of that but one of the most
monumental developments out of Canada
out of Ottawa was Marcus wheat
Marquess was developed by the Saunders
brothers out of the Experiment Station
at Ottawa beginning with with a cross
and actually this is one of the earliest
examples of making a by parental cross
of materials to develop a new line of
you name it in this case it was hard red
spring lee most of
the development work being done at
States and by companies were selections
out of land races or out of farmer held
populations of small grains or
introductions that mark Carleton or
Hansa might have made cou banca for
example was a durum wheat introduced by
by by Hansen and COO Banco was developed
and as a durum wheat variety in the
northern Great Plains out of that a
selection called Acme durum was released
by South Dakota State University but it
wasn't a reading program per se it was a
selection program this was a breeding
program there developed Marcus wheat
the parents were read Calcutta and read
5 red Fife was overwhelmingly popular
spring wheat in Canada in the Northern
Plains but they made this cross for an
improvement of that it was put into
production in the early turn of the
century in Canada and ultimately arrived
in the northern Great Plains in about
1912 but it had poor stem rust
resistance so it's still susceptible to
stem rust so let's go back to McFadden
McFadden was following the wheat harvest
northward in observing wheat making
scientific observations of wheat and
stem rust and other things and he
eventually established this theory and
kept in mind that people were very
concerned about Barberie and trying to
eradicate Barberie and that would solve
the problem but Edgar was of a mind that
actually spores were being harbored in
Texas
their systems the spring weather systems
that would come about every spring some
years worse than others would start
delivering through these low pressure
systems they would start delivering
spores up the Great Plains to infect the
crop as it developed throughout the
springtime then in the fall when the
weather systems change like now but you
get these systems that then bring down
those spores and redistribute them back
into Texas in Mexico so he felt
disrupting he eventually in his career
if we can disrupt this Puck's any a
pathway or the puck sending a highway as
it was called that would be another
mechanism or another approach to
controlling stem rust especially in
North America now here's Edgar McFadden
later in his career in his office at
College Station Texas and I have it here
to just kind of get into a little Side
Story so I had the honor just a couple
years ago of meeting a person that was
an undergraduate student employee of
Edgar's and he said when he went to ask
for a job of Edgar in this office
sitting on a chair he walked in he went
to go see Edgar and Edgar was on that
phone right there but he said come on in
sit down
so Edgar sitting down or Jim Fabian the
guy I talked to sitting down and he was
looking at this photograph on the wall
and I'll show you the photograph but
it's a very intriguing photograph it's a
photograph of some Bandidos and Edgar's
father
and Edgar was noticing this guy kind of
studying the photograph and here's the
photograph so the man on the right-hand
side standing is James McFadden Edgar's
father down in Texas and they're in the
Davis mountains and the man in the dark
coat on the horse is Pancho Villa and
they encountered Pancho Villa so the
story is from Edgar through James who
Jim fabien to me is that here Edgar is
think about Edgar took this picture and
he's sitting somewhere back here with a
guide and the reason that they were out
looking in this part of the area is the
guide the Mexican guy Edgar's father and
Edgar were looking for a new pasture to
turn their cattle into they were looking
for grazing land they they met up with
with these Bandidos and Edgar as a young
man takes a picture so click well the
Bandito that's back here were there
Edgar was where the camera is a revolver
comes out and it's pointed right at
Edgar's chest and holy hell breaks loose
they were up said if someone took a
picture of Pancho via and the guide that
was with them stepped in the way of of
the aim and calm down the situation so
no one was shot at grrrrrr McFadden was
not shot imagine imagine yourself in
that situation
now I've been held at gunpoint in other
countries and I can tell you get your
attention and you think about it and you
have a hard time getting to sleep and
things like that I imagine that would
have Edgar as well but the very next
photograph in that role is this one so
the guide that they were with the
interpreter did a a really great job
here you got these guys that are mugging
the camera you see the mountains in the
background this guy looks like the
meanest one right there look at the
bandoleros of ammunition and all of that
but that's the encounter that he had and
I'm convinced that that was a turning
point in Edgar's life because after that
event and Edgar went back on the harvest
wheat harvest followed it back up to the
northern part of the United States back
in South Dakota and when he got to South
Dakota he wrote back and said I'm not
I'm just not coming and I think that
this was the pivotal moment he wanted to
do something else with his life
something else as a career he wanted to
make an impact and doing that down in
Texas wasn't wasn't gonna get him there
so he went back to the family farm they
still owned moved back to Webster South
Dakota and his parents followed him back
to South Dakota now the family still to
this day still owns that land owned by
Balmer a Texas I don't see how you can
run many cattle out there but but
nevertheless that's what brought him
back to South Dakota in 1911
Edgar went to school bear in mind he had
an eighth-grade education he can't enter
into college and so many of the
land-grant institutions like it
Minnesota North Dakota elsewhere they
had an affiliated school called an Aggie
school it was really a boarding school
and it was put there as part of the
initial land-grant mission to provide
opportunity because communities like
Webster South Dakota didn't have high
schools
going to further their education in
those communities so Edgar entered into
the Aggie school or this official name
was the South Dakota School of
Agriculture and since it was right
across right across the street it was on
the campus of South Dakota State College
he got to meet a lot of the scientists
including Manley Champlin who was there
and Manley was an agronomist and and
initial breeder at South Dakota State
and Manley was one of those people and I
think all of you in this room have both
people that take you under their wing
they're your mentor and they further
your career and Manley Champlin was that
person for her for Edgar McFadden so
manly hired Edgar he knew that he had a
winner because he was he was self driven
he was inquisitive
he understood understood the science and
he wanted to learn more so he was busy
with a small grains research throughout
eastern South Dakota working not just on
wheat but barley and other crops and
actually Edgar as a young man and
Champlin they released I mentioned acne
as a selection out of kabocha durum
wheat they released that Edgar ever
interested in in stem rust he was
reading the literature he took note I've
seen this nope so he really took a note
that mark Carleton had observed that
durum and M are so distant relatives of
hexaploid wheat were resistant to stem
rust and leaf rust and suggested that
they might be used as a germ plasm
source in a breeding program after that
the year later john cole at south dakota
state reported that his observation
there was that they were resistant to
confirm they were resistant to stem rust
so Edgar completed his term at the
boarding school and entered South Dakota
State as a freshman at age 24 in 1914
but by that time he had already been
doing a lot of the hands-on work and a
lot of the self driven work and I
actually still have a lot of his papers
in the collection that I've archived at
the University one of those is his
English paper English ten of course
and the title of that paper was my aim
in coming to college and I think it
describes what drove him throughout his
life and he said having received a fair
education in the school of practical
experience in the University of Hard
Knocks for you talk about that episode
with poncho and hard knocks at which
institutions I learned it was usually
the man with the scientific college
training who comes out ahead in all
fields I have come to to the conclusion
that zeal and he had zeal but zeal
without knowledge will achieve great
things only with difficulty he was
looking to add to his knowledge he had
the zeal he wanted to achieve great
things and he wrote that later on that
in 1913 he decided to achieve great
things and that great thing was to have
achieved stem rust and we first
resistance in 30 1913 he said his
pathway he was doing things like
reaching out to the USDA of office of
Plant Industry asking for germ plasm
here's a letter I got out of the
National Archives asking for some beer
list barley so he was wasn't working on
just wheat but barley and corn winter
wheat
he had a publication his first
publication they screwed up his name
they have it he he was es McFadden not
EA McFadden but the paper has he a
McFadden it was on some inner specific
crosses that he was doing with rye so
back before we were developing triticale
he was doing these rye and triticum
crosses a lot of the conventional now
at the time including coming out of
places like Cornell and South Dakota
State and Harvard was that these crosses
between species were impossible and one
of the rationales are we know today that
we have these varying genomes that we
haven't then the traitor comes we have
Emmer which is a tetraploid you have
common wheat back then they kept
referring to it as triticum vulgar its
Triticum aestivum which is that
hexaploid with the three genomes but
because of these genomic differences
that it's impossible for these things to
cross and and don't waste your time but
Edgar took this approach of start
wanting to not listen to that and
develop what he could in inner specific
crosses and it's one of his earlier
attempts of that was in wheat rye
hybrids there's this paper that I
mentioned earlier on that was published
in in this genetics journal
but he had a much bigger activity and a
much bigger project that he had underway
and he was developing starting in 1913
his germ plasm base and he utilized his
farm to develop that base I mentioned
Marquess wasn't a important variety at
the time and it wasn't didn't really
come into the Dakotas until 1912 he had
it in 1913 and he was doing some pure
lines collections out of Marquess the
best-possible plants and I'm saving that
seed he obtained
Yaroslav an Emer as a planter
introduction from usda so that's a
tetraploid that he obtained seed of and
grew that out on the farm and he made
selections of of c or a selection from a
single rust-free plant off of his farm
at Webster South Dakota
he was obtaining materials also from
other lines of Emma there was a white
spring Emmer that he was working with he
was working with his own Acme durum
bluestem wheat was another land race
which was popular in the Northern Plains
the Dakotas and indeed into Canada and
then I can never pronounce this thing
but it's a mellow Durham which was
another introduction that the
Minnesotans used a stem rust uses source
for Thatcher and other releases so Edgar
went about to make the impossible cross
in 1916 and he did this he had he had
lived in a boarding house about two
blocks off of campus and so he did this
work in the backyard of his boarding
house and he would write that on July
4th he was busy making these crosses
while the rest of the city was out
celebrating the nation's independence
but he spent the 4th of July and
undoubtedly many other days paying
attention to to an thesis but making
crosses as he had learned to do in his
preparation with other crops and other
attempts before that so
was putting his two or three years of
crossing experience to work in this
project so here's the crossing block
that he had in the backyard he cost what
I think this is amazing the female
parent was the tetraploid Yaroslav Emmer
and he had Marcus those selections out
of Marcus as the male parent then he
also crossed Marcus with another
tetraploid acme durham white spring
Emmer was crossed with Marquess and the
other durham entry was crossed with
marcus as well so he made all these
hundreds and hundreds of crosses in the
backyard
I have Edgar's field notes that are in
the archive at SDSU that go from 1915 to
[Music]
1955 and when I found this page I was
flipping through it at home in front of
the TV and I just started crying because
I found something very important my wife
was kind of looking at me but let's zoom
into the top half of that so these are
just a record of what the entries were
in 1917 so let's go back I'm going to go
back a couple slides 1916 he made these
crosses and obviously he collected
progeny collected what seed he could off
of these crosses 1916 s done right so he
had a bunch of seed and he planted that
in a nursery at SDSU on the agronomy
farm in Brookings and it was planted on
March 31st in Brookings and so these are
the various entries that he had he had
some air Slav Emmer's as controls and
things like that but what I have a
highlight on here is that we have this
Yaroslav Emmer by marquess f1 cross and
then later on in pencil he said these
are the parents of hope wheat this
the only plant one plant out of all that
that had viable progeny yet one viable
seed that came out of all that work all
those other crosses that I mentioned in
1916 nothing came of that in terms of
viable seed he had one plant that came
out of this inner specific cross okay so
out of that he planted that and in 1917
off of this plant he harvested about a
hundred seeds that were the beginning of
his work actually his life's work but
there are some other challenges that
came in the way 1918 what was going on
in 1918 World War one Edgar was a
patriot a lot of his family who fought
in the Revolutionary War he was proud of
his heritage and his family and he was
proud to serve the country so South
Dakota State many other colleges
hastened the graduating class they
graduated in April out in May or June
and they graduated it in April so that
they could get these folks out and to
their postings as World War One was
going on so he graduated from South
Dakota State 1918 April 19th and then he
lets his diary there on the left-hand
side May 4th he said well I've gone and
done it I got married to Mabel the
sealed bleak sleeve better or worse well
if I if I wrote well I have written
things like that and I've gotten but we
won't go there so they did a honeymoon
out in the Black Hills and then by the
before the month was done he reported
for duty and was shipped off was
Washington but I have we always made the
assumptions that that you see here that
he went on a harvest furlough and it was
common for those folks that were still
posted domestically they could go home
and help harvest the crop because the
crop was important to the war effort
and so we always
this assumption that Edgar said I need
to go harvest the crop he just didn't
tell him that it was a hundred plants
but I have the letters that show
otherwise as soon as he was leaving in
May he was in communication with USDA
and the army say look I got this
important work going on at Highmore
South Dakota and will I get a furlough
to go collect these important samples
and they let him do it
USDA supported it and so it was upfront
it wasn't any kind of shenanigans he he
got a harvest furlough to do science and
I talked about having some forethought I
am very impressed with that
so 1918 rolls along and then November
11th we have Armistice Day let's see if
he can pick out the 5 foot 4 inch Edgar
McFadden out of this slide it's it's
obvious that no Edgar is the guy third
from the left and the front hand roll
and he looks like someone that's
encountered porch Pancho Villa only this
time he's not going to run away he he's
really looking at that camera and I get
a big kick out of that so while I head
ger was at Camp Lewis in Washington
State on November 7th yeah and I won't
read this letter but this is one of my
favorite artifacts that we have he had
this newspaper and he turned it sideways
and put it into the typewriter and wrote
this letter to his bride back in South
Dakota just asking is war over or is it
not he's been hearing news reports that
there a discussion of treaty and
armistice going on in Europe and they're
wanting to know whether they're gonna
ship off soon or they're gonna get to go
home he's also asking about what else
was going on in 1980 18 well it was the
horrendous flu epidemic that was going
on so he's asking about his father and
other family members and the health of
his mother etc but I love that he
finishes that up as your husband private
yes McFadden dear wife
dear wife your your husband yeah the war
ended and in I didn't mention earlier
that when he finished up at graduated
from SDSU his first job was working at
Highmore South Dakota I spent a lot of
my career I'm or South Dakota if you
blink while you're driving through it
you probably miss it it's we used to
send things there too really a stressful
environment there's about a hundred
about 80 miles to know about a hundred
miles west of Brookings so he lived it
high more well a year later after going
to Camp Lewis he was right back at high
more to carry forward the cereal
breeding program especially his hybrids
between Emmer and marco sweet but with
lack of federal funding this sounds
familiar doesn't it he was instructed to
terminate the program by 1920 USDA I
have the letters from the National
Archive they tried to recruit Edgar to
be in charge of the wheat program and
move him to Washington DC and he just
didn't want to do that he didn't want to
be a desk jockey he wrote and so he
decided to go back to the farm and
Webster to farm and be a seedsman and he
got licensed from South Dakota State to
take all this material with him and
further along the development of this
material on his own farm you folks could
go better go could go through this
better than me well we'll try to make a
some salient points on this but these
are this is the generational advance of
the cross that he made between Yaroslav
Emmer and Marquess
this was the key points are he advanced
lines he did a lot of bulk poppin
bulking and and population selections
for for plumpness of grain and things
like that he did this in various
environments brookings that started then
it moved to high more for a couple years
severe rust occurred in 1919 so a lot of
nice selection pressure there and in
nineteen twenty then he went to the farm
his own farm in 1921 to continue to
advance it one of the years he got
severe hail occurred so he looked for
those phenotypes that were resistant to
that hail good stock strength came out
of that 1924 by that time he had 63
selections that were grown in in single
rows or head rows by that time he was
imagine he was evaluating yield
it says stem rust leaf rust protein
gluten he didn't have a Farina graph or
mix a graph or anything like that how
did they how did he determine gluten
hmmm know what he did was pop about half
a dozen kernels in his mouth and chew it
that's what breeders were doing then so
you chew it to develop gluten and so it
was a subjective scale that people were
doing I I still remember doing that when
I was an undergraduate do that you
weren't collecting data but you're just
kind of doing a field assessment and
farmers do that today folks so they'll
take a few grains pop them in the mouth
start chewing it crunch crunch crunch
but you're trying to determine what kind
of gluten formation that you're going to
get out of there out of that wheat he
selected three lines ultimately they
were called H 44 H 49 each thirty-five
nothing really became of age 35 but H 44
and H 49 where Mon you mental to the
wheat industry around the globe in 1925
he decided to grow out H 49 that's what
he was most interested in and put it to
the test he obtained the most virulent
lines the nine most virulent strains of
stem rust and he got him from Elvin
statement just across the border and
then he also did some seedling stage
evaluations also with some stem rust
that that came from Elvin statement and
he surrounded that nursery with Marcus
wheat and he got a hundred percent
failure of the Marcus weed
one hundred percent failure of the
Marcus weed from these infections but
age 49 was absent of stem rust
completely absent after all of that
he knew he had something important so he
released a variety and he named it hope
he named it hope because it was the hope
of the industry and so
the registration certificate for hope
wheat shows Edgar as the breeder based
in Webster South Dakota
he also made available at no cost this
germ plasm to public breeders throughout
the Great Plains
so as me as a vice president in charge
of intellectual property giving away
things for free was i it wasn't allowed
really by Board of Regents policy but
just think of how important that was to
developing stem rust resistant weeds
throughout the Great Plains just
critically important so he sent this out
to his colleagues and in several
different states and in Saskatchewan and
by that by the way by this time Manley
Champlin his mentor was it University of
Saskatchewan as a weak leader
that led to several different
derivatives new varieties you can look
this up probably do it on your phone
while you're sitting there listening but
he published this work in the
predecessor of agronomy journal the
Journal of the American Society of
agronomy there's the reference he
published this in 1930 and it's just a
description of everything that I just
got done talking to you about his
description of how he developed hope
wheat and what his experiences were in
this credit this preceding thought that
such a thing was impossible and he
wrapped it up with this to talk to that
audience and he said here is good
evidence that it is possible to breed
into our common wheats desirable
characteristics that are found presently
only in different groups such as Emmer
durum einkorn ryi jalops and other
related grasses
very important I think that's a very
important paper so but he was age 34 at
that time and he had made a tremendous
success that made a big splash in the
wheat arena and then USDA wanted him
back so they hired him back and started
a new experiment station in Redfield
South North High more and that's where
he raised his family was in high
redfield South Dakota but he talks about
this period of time from 1929 to 1935 as
the worst part of his career
instead of leading his program and
developing something like hope now he
was serving a whole bureaucracy in USDA
serving other plant breeders answering
to people at the main office in
Minneapolis actually st. Paul and so he
didn't really enjoy that didn't like
that at all
but he still had this theory that he
developed that I talked about earlier
and that is we have spores that are
blowing up from the southern part of the
country into the north and then being
redistributed how is it that we're going
to combat that
coming here to talk at Cornell I have to
have present I love this photograph I'd
like to know where this building is
anybody can I'm not sure where it is but
this is the International 6th Congress
of genetics in April 1932 here at
Cornell so we have some great people
that attended there's Edgar McFadden up
front Barbara McClintock is right there
also a participant Nikolai Vavilov
Nikolai Vavilov
was at this event who knows that name
just a monumental a lot of times I asked
that at other times who was he
one one of the most important figures
out of our area of work and he hailed
out of Russia Nikolai Vavilov
and then I had Paul pocono in here he
really wasn't an agronomist or crop
geneticist his brother Wilson pocono was
a one of those plant explorers that I
mentioned earlier and his son Hugh
Pocono who I got to know as a soil
scientist at the University of Florida
Paul Pope and all was into human
eugenics and so he had an interesting
and and a disruptive career during his
life times a lot of interesting folks
there ICI statement and signed up as a
as a participant but he's not in the in
the photograph and I just just tragic
this is Nikolai Vavilov this is his mug
shot when he was arrested I just grabbed
this yesterday in my hotel room I wanted
to include it you can see how he was
kind of physically abused at his arrest
in 1940 by the Stalin regime and he died
in 1943 in a gulag and in in Russia just
tragic a tragic end to a great person in
the great mine
so Edgar was complaining to USDA and he
wanted to change his career he said I
want to do something about stem rust
more so than what I've been doing and he
said if we could develop stem rust
resistance in winter wheat and early
spring wheats in Texas what we will do
is disrupt the pot the spore base and
lower the spore count so that less
spores are blown up in the northern
Great Plains send me to Texas so they
did that they sent edgar McFadden moved
him from his loved South Dakota and he
moved back down to Texas and they
stationed in the College Station Texas
as a USDA assistant agronomist by that
time Paul Mangelsdorf had already
obtained hope and h44
and had bred that into his winter wheat
lines that he was developing in Texas
and as Edgar was arriving in Texas Paul
Mangelsdorf left to start his brilliant
career and in corn genetics at Harvard
so he left Texas A&M to go on to Harvard
and he left behind all this wonderful
germ plasm had hope in it left that back
behind for for Edgar to take advantage
of and Edgar did so what what did Edgar
do or what was going on I want to touch
about that
so remember the barbary eradication
program that the usda the US government
put millions of dollars into to
eradicate Barberie and try to lower or
base and every black dot on this map is
a farm where Barberie was eradicated and
you think about the a hundred years ago
we didn't have glyphosate we didn't have
2 4 d didn't have herbicides to do that
so we did it with rock salt and with
kerosene you identify a Barberie bush or
a plant and you just kill it
with with these with these materials
that just take it out it wouldn't
suffice to dig it out he had to use
these measures
of rock salt or kerosene to saturated
soil kerosene that's a great idea
nevertheless where was the success
here's 1935 look what look at the
percentage loss of the crop that we had
to stem rust in Minnesota North Dakota
South Dakota one hundred and five
million bushels of loss to stem rust
very little success and very little
belief that Barberie control alone was
going to be important to the control of
stem rust and we had some periodic other
infestations later on their percent stem
rust loss of 30 percent in South Dakota
and 60 percent in North Dakota just
think of the economic impact that had it
was enormous it was huge
so Edgar started working in 1935 and he
started evaluating foreign introductions
he had just had this massive evaluation
program going on of everything he could
get his hands on from the USDA
collection he got accessions from babel
off its colleague of in russia and
elsewhere materials out of south america
and he started evaluating these things
in College Station or susceptibility to
stem rust and for yield obviously and
some of the materials he was developing
came out a Mangelsdorf breeding program
hoped by Mediterranean crosses and he
was still continuing to work with stake
he had this is just a summary of what I
just got done saying he was making some
releases 1938 he released Austin Austin
where it was really a cross that was
done by mangles Mangelsdorf and then
Edgar made the selections and that was a
hope derive Seabreeze was a soft red
spring wheat that he also developed out
of the out of that material
he developed a wonderful collaboration
with her Nasir's
is that a name that that people
recognize Edgar McFadden and Ernest
Sears started to do their own intensive
work of interspecific crosses and
develop aneuploid and they published
together
Edgar McFadden and Ernest Sears 1946 the
origin of triticum spelt ax and it's
free thrashing hexaploid relatives the
same title two citations in the Journal
of heredity volume 37 page 81 and also
volume 37 107 solo kind of a version of
Part one and Part two interesting read
some of our earliest understandings of
how we evolved over the years a lot has
changed since that paper but it's an
interesting paper and he wrote in there
he said McFadden wrote that he
postulated in 1913 that vulgar wheats
were fixed hybrids between Emmer's and
another weld relative and he said he
started preliminary experiments in the
summer of 1913 so we're gonna jump into
a different phase in the talk and that
is let's look at Mexico so Edgar's
trying to develop these stem rust
resistant lines in Texas Vice President
Henry Wallace made a a trip before the
presidential elections in 1940 down to
Mexico we were worried about Mexico
joining the Axis powers prior to our
involvement in World War two and he came
back and said you know what what we can
do to prevent Mexico or or mitigate the
risk of medical Mexico be joining the
Axis powers is to help them with poverty
and to help them with food security
and bring some of our agricultural
research expertise to Mexico and he also
wrote that if we do that let's focus on
beans corn and wheat and if it's wheat
we're gonna focus on stem rust
resistance and nitrogen fertility to get
the protein level up so there was a
delegation funded by the Rockefeller
Foundation a statement was part of it
mangles Dorf Bradfield I believe was on
this as well dr. Brad field out of
Cornell Irene Bradfield Halden our Baron
Emerson we're next door to Brad field
comes from they did a massive tour of
the entire country to discern what the
problems are of common people in Mexico
and including establishment of of some
of their operations in Japan go just on
it right outside of Mexico City with
those recommendations of focusing first
on stem rust
where are they gonna go where are they
going to get their materials well
they're gonna go to edgar McFadden who
happens to be living in College Station
Texas and Edgar wrote back to this to
this Rockefeller group and he had three
recommendations I'll only provide two of
those and he said let's do chip n go
experiment 1 that's what his handwritten
note said chip Ingo experiment 1 and
these are bulks from Edgar McFadden he
provided 60 bulks including 15 crosses
of some a Mangelsdorf material and some
of the other materials with with some
other introductions that came out of
South America
and he also provided his new variety
Austin and then experiment 2 where wheat
selections 44 misil xions that he just
provided and said start evaluating these
he laid out all the experimental designs
and how to analyze the data he just laid
it all out for them black and white and
sent it and shared it and that's what
they did in Mexico it was being led by
Dutch Farrar George Farrar who later
became president of the Rockefeller
Foundation but Dutch hereare took that
advice and implemented it and by the way
he was also doing some collections of
accessions within Mexico itself to see
if there might be something that
underneath that selection pressure there
might be something of value and so he
started this program in Mexico in 1943
ultimately
forward by December 1944 they had the
100 best phenotypes in the field and
then they they drew those selections
down to the 20 best now this individual
dr. Borlaug he wasn't on the scene until
December of 1944 okay so all that work
had been done by the time Norman Borlaug
arrived in Japan go Mexico he had a
wooden table the packets of seed much of
this were hope derivatives that were
provided in the program was it
visualized and drafted by Edgar McFadden
but they were calling say they
communicated with one another but that's
the start that's the great head start
that Norman Borlaug God ultimately the
Rockefeller Foundation identified five
lines of promise that they increased to
seed seed increase they got you know
three three tons of our Rockefeller
Foundation number to 11 a ton of this
four tons of 209 etc three of these were
hope derivatives from McFadden's
selections in Texas so the crosses
weren't made in Mexico they were made by
McFadden at Texas McFadden was hired as
a consultant by the Rockefeller
Foundation and made a site visit in 2008
he looked at the information they did
site visits
long story short Rockefeller 2012 so
there's 2012 that's a tree go supreme by
116 cross that was eliminated and
discarded but everything else was
advanced or a variety release including
the
that has a hope background was released
as supremo anotherís Frontera and these
were released as varieties by the Texas
Agricultural Experiment Station it's in
crop science as the variety release and
Edgar McFadden in that information was
was named us as the breeder of the
material the target audience were
farmers not only in Texas but in Mexico
and the idea was to have a stem rust
resistant wine dominating the landscape
to disrupt stem rust for development and
thereby protecting the rest of the core
of the United States
this is one of those things that you get
from the family and when you open up the
file say wow where did this come from
this is a photograph in the Houston
Chronicle of Edgar and norman borlaug
talking with a farmer in Texas about
supremo and the farmer was very happy
and impressed with the yield he was
getting out of that kind of a testament
testimony 1951 so late in the utility of
supremo and I say late in the utility
because a letter came out in 1950 out of
the rust lab at the University of
Minnesota out of statement slab that
trouble was brewing a new race race 15 B
was making its presence in the northern
Great Plains it's the most virulent race
ever isolated in North America and it
was starting to take out varieties that
were previously deemed to be resistant
to stem rust
long story short eventually it made its
way and got established in the southern
United States as well including Texas
and including Mexico and it essentially
took out supremo so the the breeding
program under Norman Borlaug they had to
develop varieties that were a
combination of Hope background and
Kenyan backgrounds to be able to
withstand stem rust and seedling stages
as well as adult stages
George Farrar wrote this about McFadden
in 51 and he called him dr. McFadden he
never had a PhD but he had a by that
time an honorary Doctorate from South
Dakota State University so he was
calling him dr. McFadden of College
Station provided bulk wheat in the early
days of the program in Mexico and I'll
just kind of go down to the bottom line
he says we're not for the fact that
these varieties must now be withdrawn
because of 15b there's no doubt the
supremo would be the single most
important in Mexico so he was thanking
McFadden so what was this what was this
about hope we what was going on well the
person that that unti 'zed all of that
the person that took the baton from that
work and really did the genetics work
was Bob McIntosh at the University of
Sydney out in Australia and I've gotten
to know Bob through this through this
work that I've been doing about McFadden
and he's gotten to know McFadden and we
had Bob and Brookings just last May as
part of the Fadden symposium so I stolen
some of his slides and Bob so what Bob
said about hope in age 44 is that yes
indeed at the time of release hope in
age 44 were highly resistant to stem
rust and it goes back to a couple
important genes one of those used to be
sr one it's recognized as that's our
ninety was one and that's primarily the
source of resistance for seedling stages
of resistance in in these varieties and
there's this sr2 in sr2 is still
recognized as the most important
resistance gene to adult stages of stem
rust stem rust expression in in adult
plant stages it's still we're still
counting on sr2 in varieties and places
against ug99 and you know other other
problems that are out there
so it's about sr2 and sr9 I'm running
out of time so I'm going to go through
these a little bit quicker
so that's the bottom line that we have
right there sr2 has some pleiotropic
effects we are we always see some black
pseudo black chaff or brown necrosis in
varieties that that are expressing sr to
one is linked to the other
that's an anti it's not a very
attractive trait to have expressed in
wheat the wheat industry familiars don't
especially like it it doesn't really
impact yield or impact the quality or
performance per se but it is is a anti
quality trait that people don't like but
if you see black shaft you have sr too
so it's a nice marker to be used for if
sr2 is what you're looking for and you
can see some of it sometimes sr to or
the black chaff causes a miss diagnosis
with other diseases like bacterial wilt
so it causes people to unnecessarily
treat fungicides on those types of
varieties okay I'll head into the finish
line here just talk about recognition
1945 so as the World War was ending this
article comes out written by a w
Erickson actually I didn't know this was
in existence until Cindi sent it to me
but this is a little write-up that sold
for 25 cents that corrects all stores
and things like that and it was about
McFadden and how he developed hope and
it's essentially the same thing that was
published in 1930 but it had some other
had some other information in that and
in this article this little booklet
Erickson attributed winning World War 2
to hope wheat
because a war is fought with guns and
butter right so we have to feed our
troops we have to feed the people that
we are occupying and liberating so
because of our development in wheat and
the success that it had on the wheat
industry we could occupy and save Europe
post-war Europe and we could save
post-war Japan because of the abundance
of wheat that we had during that period
of time and we would not have had that
if not for hope and so he was
attributing to that and by a way I'm
drank that kool-aid myself obviously me
that led to other honors and
recognitions Reader's Digest had a big
write-up on him and Texas he was a
scroll of honor and the chem merging
society I'll talk a little bit about
October 10th 1947 McFadden appreciation
day back in South Dakota the governor
was there and you can see he's a fellow
the American Society of agronomy another
so a whole host of honors and
recognitions the state of South Dakota
because of his work in Texas recognized
him for disrupting the spore base and
saving wheat industry up and down the
Great Plains the state of South Dakota
brought him back and they built this
granite monument to Edgar McFadden in
his home town of Webster South Dakota
there was a big deal that Governor was
there to speak I have all the speeches
and and such and that's Edgar there
receiving his recognition and that's
that's how it looks today well not today
it's under three feet of snow today but
but that's how it looks today
it's still there in Webster South Dakota
and when I'm driving down highway 12 I
always make a stop that's some some
illustrations and The Reader's Digest
article USDA recognized him with the
Distinguished Service Award they stowed
on him in National Mall there's a
theater there by Washington Monument
right there on the mall and that that's
where Edgar received his
recognition in DC it was at this
graduation event that he got the
honorary doctorate degree at South
Dakota State University in 1955 he
received a letter from the John Scott
metal award people so the John Scott
award is very prestigious might not have
ever heard of it and I didn't hear of it
until after I was diving in the McFadden
but it goes to the most deserving men
and women whose inventions have
contributed to some outstanding outcome
and it started in the early 1800s by
John Scott he was a Scottish druggist
and he entrusted money to the city of
Philadelphia which was the heart of our
innovation it was the Silicon Valley of
the United States back in the day and so
he gave this money in trust to the city
of Philadelphia to periodically
recognize those people that make
monumental innovative contributions to
society and some other recipients have
been Madame Curie and Thomas Edison the
Wright brothers Jonas Salk you recognize
all of those names and he got a letter
saying we would like to know about you
because we're considering you for for
this honor and he wrote back saying I
didn't invent stem rust resistance it's
part of nature so they had to convince
him to be cooperative
they asked elven statement to support
his nomination and elven kind of said no
one really special
because we were releasing fat sure and
other other lines as well and that was
that was elven statement really
nevertheless they were persistent and
they conferred this honor on to Edgar
McFadden he received it at the Americans
are the Triple A s meetings in I think
it was in Atlanta in December late
December of 1955 and then ten days later
that you're passed away
so um there's this headstone Cindy and I
have visited his headstone in in College
Station and it says a workman that
needeth not be ashamed he fell in his
sleep through this work I've gotten to
know the family very closely a Cindy and
I are both honorary family members they
call us cousins and all of this so we're
very much involved in this this effort
as a family so he was a workman that
needeth not be ashamed just think about
what he went through he was the son of
pioneers and community developers
he himself was a farmer and he practiced
agricultural science made a life of
commitment self self-sacrifice and a
commitment to science he was self driven
self-motivated he often called how how
proud he was as a veteran that he did
the nation's called with the colors I
like that that term that he used he used
another term that I forgot to mention
that I loved and that was radical plant
reading this this notion of
interspecific crosses a hundred years
ago it was thought to be impossible he
called that radical plant reading and he
would talk give seminars on radical
plant reading and I hope all of you that
are plant breeders or radical plant
breeders as well to carry forward that
legacy numerous crop varieties that he
released in his career and I believe he
was the most innovative plant reader
during that preview time 1913 to 1956 so
with that that's the end of my talk you
know thank you so much for this welcome
and for a great audience I can take some
questions if we if there's time this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at Cornell edu